uh
i'm i'm not making any any comments on
that um
other than you know i've i've i've told
you guys this for the last you know a
couple of years i've always just taken
it one year at a time
and uh and kind of reevaluate each off
season and then you know find the things
i want to get better at and
i love the patriots i mean they they
obviously uh you know they got a
it's a greatest organization and you
know playing for mr craft all these
years
and that for coach belichick i mean
there's
[Music]
you know there's nobody who's had a
better career
i would say to me you know just being
with them
so i'm very blessed i don't know what
the future looks like so i'm not going
to predict it so
we should have one tonight
and uh
wish we've done a lot of things better
over the course of the season but we
just didn't
tom brady may not know what the future
looks like but i know this he gets to
determine the future yeah he can do
whatever he wants to do stay with the
patriots retire or sign with another
team and robert kraft
told peter king of football morning in
america that his preference would be
that brady stays or retires well you
don't want him to go somewhere else
right you don't want him to compete with
you you don't want him to test out the
theory sure of brady without belichick
versus belichick without brady you don't
want that football's hard enough without
this side drama that would happen but
you know in the media business we love
chaos right and tom brady leaving the
patriots drew brees leaving the saints
both will be free agents that is the
kind of chaos that makes the off-season
rumor mill go around no doubt about that
i mean i still i can't imagine
that he wants to go somewhere else or
ends up playing in another uniform tom
brady i mean come on this is you know
this is arguably bigger than michael
jordan here to make it interesting yeah
what do you want to put on it double or
nothing on the steak dinner that you're
never going to give sure let's double or
nothing double or nothing
i say he goes one more year in new
england i say he goes to a new team gosh
i just can't imagine but maybe you're
right i will say this now when it comes
to brady and brees like
i think brady has more of a future
somewhere else than breeze does i think
brees
really needs sean payton he needs sean
payton to devise the short passing game
and all the things we've talked about
again it's the second playoffs in a row
we're going to leave and go man the
saints and drew brees can't push the
ball down the field it leads to defenses
being really aggressive and taking away
a lot of the bread and butter players in
the offense tom brady i don't have that
same question you know tom brady do i
think he'll thrive away from new england
no not necessarily but his arm is still
big time and he still has size and
things like that to where there's no
throw on the field that he can't make at
this age to where the oh the field's
totally open so uh but i still just man
i just i can't
la miami i just can't see it i don't
know i got to see it to believe it i'm
saying there's one more year but the
same thing with peyton manning i know
but peyton manning's still ready for
yours in his career like but we didn't
know what he was i know because of the
neck injury but it still wasn't your 20
what about brees where would brees go
back to the chargers
i don't know maybe something like that
see brees to me has to be a little bit
more picky because he needs to find an
offense that really fits him you know
that that's again i think at his age and
where he's at so that there's no there's
no sean payton coaching that's what i'm
saying that's right that's the thing you
can't like where are you going to go
where do you go where you find an
offense just like the one exactly that's
my that's my thing with drew brees so i
both are going to be fascinating
decisions and yeah i mean with taysom
hill in the background in new orleans
that makes it you know uh interesting
too because you and i know we both heard
from many people in the nfl that hey
sean payton fancies taysom hill and sees
him as the future and teddy bridgewater
is going to be a free agent as well
right and and he stayed with the saints
instead of going to the dolphins this
past year
because of the belief that he would have
a shot to be the successor to drew brees
but between hill and bridgewater i see a
much greater ups much greater upside
with hill yeah hill has superstar traits
i mean he has a big time arm and
his ability to run the ball is special
he could be a
poor man's version of lamar jackson what
does he what does he do with those
underneath routes the intermediate route
well yeah we'll see you're right we've
seen the timing we saw better this
preseason to give us hope that oh he can
continue to improve and get better we'll
see where it goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports